[Music]
welcome to another episode of vm end to
end a show where we have a former maybe
even reformed vm skeptic and a vm
enthusiast my friend brian together to
hash out all things vms
brian thank you for being here uh what
is this episode about you just told me
it's special i had to be here and that
was it yup i think you're going to like
this
it's where i admit that vms might not
always be the answer
uh can you say that one more time vms
might not always be the answer it
depends and so with that in mind i
wanted to bring in an expert colleague
of ours who has been a sys admin who has
you know kind of run all kinds of
different machines and
um you know who's now focused on
serverless welcome katie
hello thank you for inviting me brian
yes and katie i'm extra excited i don't
know if you you just heard what brian
said about
maybe vm's not always being the answer
uh didn't you work on
get to play around with the migrate for
cloud run tooling i did
brian have you heard about this one it's
very cool
you know honestly i think i heard about
it and let me make sure i'm right is
this the is this the thing that
claims to be able to kind of make
containerized setups out of what's
running on a vm
yes
and it works i tried it
wait okay like now okay i have to admit
i was like so skeptical of this you know
it's like so much often considered kind
of an anti-pattern and like you can't
just kind of lift this whole vm into a
container containers aren't vms all this
sort of stuff that i i didn't actually
look at it as carefully as i probably
should because i it didn't pass my
is this real test so how was i wrong
about that
i had the same sort of thoughts it's
like but if i've got a complex vm that's
got all these different services some of
them are socket driven some of them are
port driven how am i gonna take that
from a vm and put it into a container
but
i found that it was actually really
cleverly done um what i did was i built
a very special bespoke crystalline vm
and i installed postgres from system
packages i set that all up i
set up a django website on there i had a
whole bunch of user uploads on there so
i was a very bespoke vm
and then
i ran it through
migrate for cloud run and that was able
to containerize the vm identify what
services were running and then i had the
choice to disable all the services and
then
re
create them well not recreate redefine
the services there's a particular yaml
that you can define
services hyphen config.yaml
where like you would define a whole
bunch of uh systemd services you can
define new services so i disable all the
services that's running on this
containerized vm and then i declare a
new one which is just my web service uh
on a port and then when that's running
in cloud run all i do is say see that
port go listen to that
uh one thing i did find though that this
worked really well when combining it
with the database migration service so i
could
take my
locally running postgres database and
then migrate that into cloud sql
so i could migrate my vm twice but it
meant that i was able to go from one
very special vm that if it went away i'd
be very sad into
manage cloud sql and then into a
containering cloud run that can scale to
zero survive restarts all that kind of
fun it was actually really neat i'm
interested in sharing more about that to
some of our customers there's two things
i want to ask about here one first you
define the mapping between uh ports and
sockets and whatnot but two you said
that you had a vm or you wrote a custom
scope bespoke vm and then you
transitioned it into a more managed
service
why why would you go up the stack that
way
well
karma
what do you want to have to worry about
me personally nothing i i want to write
code and i want to be done with it
that's what i want to worry about you
know
for brand new green fields projects or
proof of concept projects you can do
that straight away with cloud run where
it's such an abstraction on top of the
vm on top of the kubernetes on top of
everything
you just need to containerize your code
and go run it
but there are going to be brownfields
projects where you're going to have
something that exists and you're going
to if you want to
pull it up into a serverless system
you're going to have to do that
migration step
but
with managed services
you don't have to worry
about a number of things like
who are you talking with the other day
was it gabe
about databases
yes it was he talked to us about
databases hosted how to decide when to
host on a vm and some database migration
stuff
yeah i mean in my bespoke virtual
machine i would have to worry about
maintenance and package system system
package updates and
backups of my database
once i'm in cloud sql that's all there
by default
what do you want to have to worry about
okay well let's say let's let's get an
example let's ground it in reality
say one of our two co-hosts on the show
was writing a small back-end application
uh no front-end it just uses apis goes
from a command line type deal
where would i want to run that
or sorry where would our co-host whoever
it is want to run
that well carter and or brian
it depends
it sounds like you may not even have to
worry about cloud run because with cloud
run you would have to
have a container that listens on a port
and then serves stuff but it sounds like
if you've just got a function
you might just want to go straight to
cloud functions where you just supply
a
function
a method a
function description with parameters and
then it gives you
it returns data
and just copy paste that up into cloud
functions and everything else is handled
for you
mm-hmm can can i ask a question brian i
see that you've got something on your
mind so let me sneak this one in
um i'm used i'm very used to with say
like kubernetes just putting a web app
in a container and running that
what is the difference between cloud run
which i'm not really familiar with and
something like a kubernetes there
cloud run is just managed kubernetes
oh
so then uh like like gke basically yeah
uh cloud run runs on top of k native
which itself runs on top of
gke which itself runs on top of vms
which itself runs in google data centers
which itself runs on servers
you don't have to worry about so many
things when you move up this abstraction
stack you're still using the underlying
technology
but you don't have to worry about it
i love what you just said their
abstraction stack like i i like to think
about it you know you talked about cloud
run and we've got app engine and oh
sorry we've talked about functions and
we've got app engine and cloud run and
kubernetes and vms and like like you
said if you've got a greenfield thing
like you probably want to start at the
top of this abstraction stack and kind
of work your way down and if you have
something existing that's already
running in a vm or on a computer
somewhere it's probably going to be
easiest to start you know towards the
bottom um
nice
i mean yeah it's very nice i remember
back in the day
if i wanted to try to get
logs or debug a machine
i would have to physically go to the
data center and wheel out a little
trolley and plug in a keyboard and mouse
nowadays
depending on where in the stack i am i
either ssh directly into the machine or
i go into cloud logging and everything
is already there
i don't have to physically drive to
where my machine is anymore i don't have
to worry about that my life is very much
better now i do not have to physically
go and plug in keyboard and mouse into
servers
right i yeah i can i can relate to this
uh being in the military i used to work
on some very old computer technology
i'm glad i don't have to deal with that
anymore
but there's something i wanted to dig
into a little bit deeper here
your thought process behind
thinking about well what do you want to
have to worry about what do you have to
manage
is that based on what resources the
application is touching
for example if the application is
touching a web port or a websocket then
you might have to use like a cloud run
as opposed to a serverless
it depends
if you have a system that relies on
specific gpus you might have to choose a
service where you can define those
the cloud run container contract is just
tell me what port on this container i
should listen on and i will serve that
for you you can have anything you want
inside that container
i have colleagues that have put fortran
into that container and cobalt into that
container
as long as it listens on a port
it's fine
but if you need to start worrying about
not just one container but multiple
containers you might want to drop down
into gke and handle your orchestration
at that level if you want to have to
worry about specific types of cpu
architecture you might need to drop down
into vms but if all you want to do is
when someone
goes to my http url they get back a
response
then some of these higher level
abstractions are going to be the
solution for you but you don't just have
to choose one you can mix and match
oh bryant
okay so i i actually i'm inspired by
katie's you know kind of
picture painting here and the it depends
um so
what if we would kind of keep with the
theme of vms right because that's this
like conversation
but
you know compare and contrast like if
you were going to use functions versus
vm like when would you use functions
instead when would you choose a vm when
would you combine them um and kind of go
through the whole stack abstraction
stack you know one at a time and and dig
into each
i am so here for this because as soon as
you said that my first question was oh
wait i can use serverless and vms
together in the same application what
like
is that a thing so yes i want to go and
i want to find out what tools i can use
in place
or begrudgingly with vms if that's what
i need to do
awesome katie would you be up for coming
back and dig deeper on some of these
season three season three
[Laughter]
take that as a year three
well you know if you're watching at home
i just want to say uh you know thanks
for sticking with us for so long next
season it sounds like we're going to go
on a little bit of an adventure and
explore different use cases uh for some
of these abstractions on top of vms and
when you might want to use them
so thank you so much katie thank you for
being here brian as always thank you yo
so if you are at home watching this i'm
sure there's a couple things that uh we
talked about today that may be spurred
your thoughts some questions that you
have about vms and using them with some
of these different tools and services so
drop those in the comments we'll check
those out and stick around because next
season it's going to get weird
that's vm end-to-end thank you
[Music]
you